How's it going bros? My name is Pewdiepie,
I don't remember..ending the last episode here
Oh yeah. The f*cking cage thing.
Okay, fine. You know what? Fine.
Let's just do this real quick...
We know what's gonna happen. I'm gonna take a napsie. See you in a second.
Okay, we are back.
No, wait. Wait a minute. This is... No, no. We're not quite back yet. Sorry.
Woah!
What?
No way!
Trico!
(Faint) Trico!
Trico! TRICO!
TRICO! IT'S TRICO EVERYBODY!
(???)
(As Trico)I found you through the mountain!
(As Trico) Whattup boy?
(As Trico)Hey, how ya been Pewds?
(As Trico) I missed ya
(As Trico) Do you got any food?
Jesus Christ... Just get me out of the cage!
Please.
I'm so bored. This part was so boring!
Yes, I have absolutely no patience whatsoever. I am so sorry.
Trico!
Awwww! That's so cute!
He's cuddling a cage!
Can you help me out please?
D'you gotta plan?
What are you doing, smelling the grass? I need you to help me.
Do something damn it.
Thank you so much. Wow. That really helps.
That really changes everything.
He's just smelling around.
Where were you?
You nearly drowned me, by the way.
Just do something!
Here we go.
Awww
It's so cute. Oh my god.
Missed you too man, but I need you to get me outta this cage!
ASAP. It's taken way too long.
Alright, if you push me up here,
...that'd be great. Can you do that?
Trico!
Push me!
Give it a little push!
Give it a little nu-
There it-
Hey that's so cool! He did it!
Thank you!
Aaahh!
Oh my f*cking head. I should put on this helmet that's inside here.
Oh.. Okay. Here we go.
Oh boy. This should be scary.
Be careful now. Careful!
F*ck.
Oh my god..
Alright, well it's been scary.
Oh my god! Ahh!
I'm fine! I'm fine.
I'm fine. Don't you worry.
Can I get outta here now?
Oh no.
F*ck!
This is not going great.
I am aware. But I'm trying my f*cking best here, okay?
Damn it..
Trico, I need your help buddy.
Where are you when you need me?
There it is. Look at this.
We are really trying to kill ourselves..Jesus.
What's your strategy here dude?
(Laughing)
Keep rolling, rolling, rolling, rolling.
What? Oww!
F*ck!
All the way that we went up!
Oh boy. We do not wanna fall down the stairs though!
Bad news is waiting down the stairs.
Dude you really just aught to put on that f*cking helmet
There we go.
Suicide!
Trico, you here?
Am I - Oh god, oh god. Bad idea.
Holy shit, that's awesome!
Ohhh
Ohhhh I get it!
That's so cool!
I just need to make our way to the other one!
That's it. Steer, steer.
Now forward.
Shit, steer.
Steer.
Steer my dear.
There it is! We did it!
Now we should fly up.
Bzzuuuee
Or that!
Or that.
Or. That.
I was just about to-
I'm free!
Tricoo!
(As Trico)Oh you're back Pewds! I missed you!
Dude, I missed you too.
That was mean Trico!
And I climbed up-
Oh my god. Are we getting attacked?
What happened?
I missed you.
I missed you man.
Oh!
He's so cute.
Calm down Trico. Calm down. Calm down. Calm down.
Aww he's hungry!
Let's see if we can try and make him go to sleep. That'd be cute.
I know you're tired man.
I know you've been through a lot looking for me and-
I appreciate that so now why don't you take a little nap and I'll go find you a snack.
You want a little Red Bull as well so you can a little feel better?
Ah that's right.
Okay.
Maybe we can take the elevator back, the other one. You know what I mean.
Yeah, that seems like it's safe.
'K', let's go!
I don't know how this qualifies as an elevator-
Oh, it's going down. Okay.
A 'downevator'.
Am I right?
I'm here all night.
Doing great jokes.
There he is.
Okay, so..
I know there's a barrel. There's one behind me here.
It's really annoying me cause I don't know how to get past it.
Maybe it's some way around?
I don't know how!
The helmet! The game is tipping me.
Oh, that's a good puzzle. Thank you for revealing the whole puzzle for me.
Oh my god, I'm an idiot!
Alright, let's do that.
(As Trico)You're a f*cking idiot Pewds, you needed to get the fucking helmet.
(As Trico)I can't tell you because I'm a f*cking cat fish salmon..dog...fish. Shut up.
Here we go. Of course!
Thank you game!
Here we go.
F*cking idiot. Okay. Here we go.
Shut up.
That's why we went all the  way with the helmet inside!
Helmet inside, helmet inside.(Miscellaneous rapping noises) They have the helmet inside.
That's not the lyrics. Okay great.
I'm not surprised that I -  Okay. Alright. F*ck you.
Not you of course. The other one.
Okay. See, I knew where it was at least.
That's not a bad quality. To knoowwww-
Unlimited pow- ah shit. F*ck.
Okay. It's okay.
I have been trained - oh my god shit.
Okay, alright.
Whatcha gonna do huh?
What ya gonna fucking do huh?
Won't ya come here?
F*cking f*ck off b*tch. I'm gonna get the f*cking keg.
You gotta a problem with kegs? You got a problem with me.
That's -
Shit, hurry up. Hurry up.
Nailed it. You nail - You nailed it you f*cking idiot.
Don't touch me!
You f*cking -
*sshole
Yeah, you want a hug? You better hug someone else.
Trico.
My *sshole is spread right here for ya.
Oh really?
Alright. Real nice.
There was a trick!
Ah f*ck.
Panic!
Got him!
(Laughing)
No! Don't f*cking touch me!
You don't f*cking touch me.
Oh you're using (?)
Sh*t!
F*ck!
Not to anything but the - oww. Oww.
Throw it. Throw it!
Throw it up!
Good job. F*cking moron.
If you weren't such a f*cking retard,
Oh how about that? It didn't f*cking work. How about that?
Wait a minute, can I just walk up with it?
What the f*ck?
God damn it, I'm a -
Bye!
Bye b*tch!
(As Trico)Well, well, well. Look who finally made it.
(As Trico) Oh my god.
(As Trico)Is that a snack?
(As Trico) Did you know I love snacks?
(As Trico) Oh my god, is that -
(Sniff, sniff)
(As Trico) Ohhh! It's Pringles!
There you go. You got it.
Take the Pringles
Take it
Take it. Take the Pringles.
Take the Pringle.
Take the - ahh.
We did it, you ate the Pringles. Now let's go.
Can we go?
Can we go now?
I thought it was weird cause this place is so cool design,
The fact that we spend so little time in here is kind of a shame cause it's such a pretty cave.
You look at it.
If you appreciate it, it's architectural beauty.
Trico!
He really doesn't listen to me.
And errm, I don't know what to do about that.
Did your horns grow? Are you getting more horny?
I'm twelve
Here we go. Nice.
And then just one more jump Tricketroo.
(As Trico) Jesus Christ, I f*cking hate ya.
Trico, your left horn is bigger than your right one.
That's a bit awkward.
Haha
(As Trico) Shut up.
(As Trico) Shut your f*cking mouth.
Alright, where do we - where are, where is this going now?
Oh, oh, oh. He, he -
Trico!
Go! Go! Go! Go! Go! Go! Go!
Alright. He did a mini jump. Fine.
You know what, fine.
(As Trico) Where could I go now Pewds?
(As Trico) Cause I don't know!
Hey, how about up, where we - oh okay.
Jesus f*cking -
Woaah!
My god, that was a little higher than I thought.
Hey, look at that! We made it back.
No wonder it took you ages to find me. Jesus bro.
(As Trico)Now, that other Trico went through that wall, It was very cool. He did it very elegantly.
(As Trico) I'm gonna find him, I'm gonna skin him, and then we're gonna sleep in his skin.
Ah okay. You wanna clean yourself a little bit?
(As Trico) Nah that's fine. I've got plenty of -
Ah Jesus.
It will be back soon.
Oh!
He's saying the other thing!
Good boy, can you do that jump?
Oh yeah!
Oh, oh! Go, go!
Trico, Jesus you f*cking cra -
What am I looking at?
What the hell am I looking at?
Another one.
Do it man.
Get up there boy.
Yes!
We're doing great dude. We got such good progress there.
I think I recognise where we are. Oww my feet..
Just broke both of them.
Let's have a look outside. This is so pretty!
Oh my god. Look at that.
Woah!
Are we like, high up now? This looks like wintery.
Or is it just the light?
What are you doing?
Dude I'm inspecting the view. You're being an *sshole.
What are you saying?
You need an aspirin?
Well, you know you're not the only one.
Awww. Awwwww. That's so cuuuuteeee!
It's such a loving creature.
How can you use it for war?
That would be like having a little Pomeranian out in the battle with full amour and shield.
I missed you too buddy.
I missed you too.
But it's time for us to progress in this game.
And progress will be made only.
By me playing it.
So f*ck you and your cuddles.
I can go up here by myself.
I'm going to die, am I?
Oh, god. Oh, god. I'm going to die.
There we go.
(As Troci) What are you doing there Pewds?
(As Troci) Don't worry about it. I have a deep, epic voice now, which means I can climb much better.
(As Troci) That's right.
(As Troci) I can see your tiny little balls again.
Shut up
(As Troci) I can smell them too.
Look at this jump.
(As Troci) Look at that jump huh?
And I am a dead person.
I am the worst player at this game, I realize now.
You, you if you're watching, are watching the worst let's play ever of this game.
That's awesome! Don't you feel special?
Here we go.
Okay
Woo!
Nice!
Okay, alright!
We are making our way downtown, walking fast, faces -
ahh!
passing my hometown. (Acapella)
You sing along.
(More acapella)
You should do that part
(Even more acapella)
Starting blankly on Trico's *ss
Making my way, making my way.
Through that butt hole.
(Acapella again)
And I Triko.
(Acapella)
Finding weed
(Laughing acapella?)
And now I wonder
When watching
Pewdiepie's sh*tty let's play
I could be doing
Literally anything else
There's many other let's players
out there, so why am I watching this?
tonight.
(The acapella's back)
Good one
Here we go
Boep!
Woep!
Tricky
I think I should have been the voice acting for the little boy. I think it's much better.
(As Trico) Shut the f*ck up Pewds.
Okay then. Alright.
Just listen to this,
Trico!
Huh? Pretty good huh?
Oo oaa oooo ahh
I did a (?)
Would you- would you much rather hear that? Well I suppose you are in a way.
Trico! (?)
He needs some (?) sh*t there.
(Sniff,sniff)
You mean there's sh*t? (Sniff,sniff) It smells like Edgar took a sh*t.
Woah, look at this.
This is very nice.
I really like this.
Plus, we got rid of Trico. Haha.
Hahaha
Let's see if we can open the gate for him.
I'm sure there must be a gate here somewhere.
A lever. Hey! Look who it is.
(As Trico) I miss Pewds.
(As Trico) I miss Pe- Oh my god, there you are! I wasn't-
(As Trico) I wasn't missing you
There you go buddy
Follow me, welcome in. This is my new house.
If you buy enough lambos(?), you can combine them into this house!
Oh no, it's the bad area.
This is the mean part where he goes crazy.
Stay there.
(?) Stay there.
I'm going for it though
Oh no.
Why did I go for it?
F*ck
Don't touch me, I'm f*cking -
I'll kill myself and sh*t
I hate these guys with a f*cking passion
I hope y'all f*cking die.
You remind me of.... someone really annoying.
Like me
That's probably why I don't like you.
Can you touch me here? Don't! What did I say? What did I say?
What the f*ck just happened?
No, no! Not evil Trico again!
I don't want evil Trico!
Shake it off!
Shake it off Trico!
(As Trico) But I must.... eat blood.
(As Trico) I must eat your soul
God damn it!
This is what happens.
It's me.
(As Trico) You're f*cking dead. You're f*cking dead. Who's gonna boss you around now huh?
No Trico!
Noo!
If you knew how to fight properly I'd be dead now. Clearly, you suck.
I just f*cking died.
Well that's a little awkward.
What happens now? Does it reset or..
It does this thing again where it shows us the past, it seems like.
The story behind the setting maybe. I hope.
Cause I'm very curious.
(Gasp) There's us!
We woke up by a butterfly. We don't have the sh*tty tattoos!
Woah.
Is that Trico flying?
Oh my god..
That'd be cool if his wings would grow out as well.
That would be the ultimate. That would be the ultimate.
This is our home?
Looks very cool.
Trico just-
Woah.
Maybe he attacked us? He has epic wings!
That's f*cking awesome!
That is creepy as hell.
Children!
Why don't you come and play with me, children?
Who made that armor for him?
We're having a bad dream...
What?!
What does that mean? Ah, Trico. You blew it.
Gotta watch your feathers dude.
That is strange. That is very interesting.
Aw
Okay..
(Screaming -in-game)
(Laughing)
(As Trico) Hey, how ya doing mama?
(As Trico) Just having a little snack.
(As Trico) Aww, come on. I love Pringles! Got a problem?
Oh so he's being controlled right now? Oh my god, no.
That's so f*cking cool. I love this movie.
I want a full featured film of this.
(As Trico) Dude, I just ate the kid. What do you want?
(As Trico) It's just one snack!
The question is, who put the armor on him?
Ya know? Cause clearly these guys' technology is not very advanced.
(As Trico) You think I'm a f*cking fool?
He can just fly away at any moment, you know?
Nice. I'm not nice. I mean - I don't know who I'm rooting for.
So maybe when he pooped us out we got the tatoos, you know?
That would make sense.
In a world, where Tricos are real,
Hoowa!
Be among the chosen one..
Are we the chosen one perhaps?
Well, obviously humans put armors on him.
But why? And how? And what?
So he flew. Flew as far away
To some ancient temple.
Probably.
Look at all this advanced technology.
That's so f*cking cool.
I - If we could fly with him in the end, I would be very happy.
Very, very satisfying.
I would be in (?)
All just for playing this game.
This is the first real cut scene we got so far.
I mean, we had a few, but this is the first longer one. This is so cool! I wish we had more.
That's the thing that controls him.
Tower. What a weird city.
But we were struck by lightning!
We needed a lightning rod Trico.
You're a metal piece flying in the air. What the f*ck did you expect to happen?
And that's how the game started?
No f*cking way.
That's how the game started, huh?
Awww
Baby Trico.
Wait what? So they retreived him.
The soldiers.... Who controls the soldiers?
And they put us there. They placed us there.
That's strange- that's even more strange. Why would they do that, you know?
And where do we come into place?
They chained us up.
Probably because they couldn't control us at the time.
Woah, what the? That is a barf.
That is disgusting.
Don't you just hate when you eat little boys and you barf them up? I hate when that happens.
So we came from his mouth and had the tattoos on...
Okay
A little strange, but hey. I can dig it.
Let's go to the light.
(As Trico) Sorry I ate ya kid.
(As Trico) Hope you don't mind.
And we have more tattoos on us now don't we?
Every time he eats us..
The nest...
Okay, so cause we saw it, it was so secluded. Oh my god. It must have been gigantic then!
That's so cool.
Are we dead? We don't look too good.
Hey Trico,
Could you stop f*cking eating me.
Aww
So we're an ancient creature from an ancient civilization.
But why did it- Cause he was clearly told to go and retrieve the boy.
There's something more to it.
There's something else to this.
Aww
This is so sad.
That was the game.
And nothing else.
I wanna know more about this ancient civilization.
What's gonna happen?
Haha, thanks, hahaha
Face down.
Did we die?
No, we didn't
Did we?
Sure looks dead.
But who would tell the story? Sorry, I'm using Michaels account.
He's gonna wake us up in the water?
You better not just drop him.
Haha, great. Now we're drowning.
Hey! It worked.
Thanks Trico.
Aww! He's so happy.
Yeah..
That's so cute.
Trico,
I don't think you can cuddle with nails like those.
Awww Trico.
Ahh..
Awww... So cool.
I'm so happy.
Happy, happy, happy.
I suppose it makes sense for me to keep going a little bit.
What did you say? What? Are you still listening?
Have you been tabbed out doing other sh*t? What the-
F*ck.
I'm kidding of course.
Joking.
Made a little joke.
Now let's not go back here.
What happens if we go back here? Do you think it will still go crazy?
Hey, Trico. You gonna lose it if you go here buddy?
Eat me again? That would make me look real bad.
Hup!
Oww, my everything.
Well, it seemed fine last time.
The question is, how do we get past this point.
Surely there must be a lever.
(As Trico) I don't wanna. Last time I ate ya.
(As Trico) You taste like sh*t. I don't know how to tell you.
And get me up there.
That would be good.
That would be excellent if you could do that.
Don't hurt yourself now boy.
Just put me up a li- Oh that's all I need.
Nice jump there buddy.
Jump off.
Jump off, there we go.
Now, don't be scared Trico boy.
I b- oh, he's gone.
Oh look at that I can walk down ladders now. I finally learnt how to do it.
You hold X which is weird, cause you press- actually it's not that weird. I just reall-
Did you? Oh, nevermind.
Oww.
Hey look at that. I found a lever.
If I could only reach it. It's far away.
Hwah
These tattoos that I've got on my body represent that I've been eaten three times.
It's pretty cool though.
I-I mean we definitely have more tattoos on us now.
I wonder if we could be covered by the end - Well we clearly are already.
I wonder if anyone's gonna be lame enough and get these tattoos.
I mean, actually, they're kinda cool now that I look closely.
I kinda looks like someones,
wrote on you with paint or some sh*t. I don't know.
Okay.
What do we have here?
Minecraft!
F*ck!
This way then.
Trico.
Alright, I'll be right back. F*cking hell.
Nope, nothing here.
Maybe a way to control these?
What are you doing?
Hahahaha
You're not a cat!
This has t- Oh my god, I just saw his butt hole
This has to stop Trico.
Can you break this door open?
Oh, I see. There you go.
That's where he peeps his head in.
Come on boy.
(As Trico) But I'm too fat. You said it yourself.
No, no, no. You're not.
You look great by the way. You look so good.
That's it. That's my boy.
(As Trico) Okay
(As Trico) You said I'm skinny. Here I come.
Oh Jesus.
(As Trico) Hey, how skinny am I?
You're so skinny. Just keep on a little further.
(As Trico) But I'm too - Okay.
(As Trico) Here I come. I'm so skinny.
(As Trico) Here I am.
This is so creepy and weird.
Okay, alright. I did it.
Thanks, Trico.
For nothing.
(As Trico) But you said I was skinny.
He could easily knock these over.
I don't know man. He could easily just f*cking slam this door open.
Lemme spank that *ss
Smack.
(As Trico) I'm stuck!
Okay, this way.
Clearly he can fit in here, right?
Not a problem, right?
I don't know what I'm doing.
That seems to be the case a lot of times when I play this game.
Hey look!
Trico!
(As Trico) I'm coming,
(As Trico) It's not everywhere there's a cat dog fish snake.
(As Trico) You discriminated against our nation.
That does not look normal over there.
Look at him.
(As Trico) I'm skinny. I'm skinny. I. Will. Fit.
(As Trico) I'm skinny damn it. Shut the f*ck up.
(As Trico) Skinny.
(As Trico) I'm skinny.
It looks terrifying. Look at that! What the hell!
Oh my god. (As Trico) I am skinny!
(As Trico) I'm so skinny.
There's no way you can fit dude.
(As Trico) I am the chosen skinny one.
Dude, it looks like he's in pain.
It looks like he's coming from out of the ground.
What do I do?
Enjoy the gate, b*tch.
No! What?
Another one of these.
Did we die? What happened?
We'll find out in the next episode. Leave a like if you enjoyed,
Check out the next episode here,
and I'll see you - there's two more. I'm sorry. I know it got a little confusing.
Okay, I'm sorry. I am sorry.
But it means we have more stuff to watch, so it's a good thing.
Don't you worry. Thank you so much for watching with me today. I hope you have fun,
And as always, stay awesome bros!